i don't know what to do it's like that's
okay
nobody does go do something
do the best thing that you can think of
well why does it matter how you make
decisions in your life because if you
make some stupid decisions you are
insufficient and you could rectify it as
you start to fail you fail more and more
rapidly but it also means that as you
start to succeed you succeed more and
more rapidly
even if things are going really well for
you now there's going to be a time in
the future where things are rough you
know you're going to be ill
family members going to be ill a dream
is going to fall apart you're going to
be uncertain about your employment
status like the the flood is coming
right the apocalypse is coming it's
always the case in life and you have to
be prepared for it and the question is
how to prepare for it and the answer to
that is to find a way of being that
works even under the direst of
circumstances it's like okay what have
you got under those circumstances you've
got the possibility to slowly raise
yourself out of the mire you've got the
possibility to do just what the fighter
does when he's defeated which is to say
well
regardless of the circumstances that
might have led to my defeat like even if
there were errors on the part of the
referee
this is no time to whine about it this
is a time to take stock of what i did
wrong so that i could improve it into
the future and that's the right attitude
so you lose a match which is not any
indication that you're not good at what
you do you might not be as good as the
person who beat you but if you lose the
match and then whine what you've done is
sacrifice the higher order principle of
constant improvement of your own skill
because you should be analyzing the loss
and saying the reason i lost insofar as
it's relevant to this particular time
and place is the insufficiencies i
manifested that defeated me and i need
to track those insufficiencies so that i
can rectify them in the future and if
i'm blaming it on you or the referees or
the situation then i'm not taking
responsibility and i'm not pushing
myself forward it's going to affect how
you make decisions in your life
something that matters affects how you
make decisions in your life well why
does it matter how you make decisions in
your life because if you make some
stupid decisions you're going to
increase the sum total of suffering a
lot you're going to do stupid things to
yourself you're going to do stupid
things to other people and you're not
going to be as good a person as you
could be so not only will you do stupid
and terrible things but you won't have
manifested the good in the world that
you could have manifested so that's the
lap so you write an essay so that you
can think and you think so that you can
live properly and so you write damn
carefully you make sure that every
single bloody word is a word that you
want to use and you make sure the
phrases that you put the words in are as
solid as they can be and you make sure
the sentences are well constructed and
that they're organized into proper
paragraphs and the paragraphs are
sequenced and the content of the thing
matters and you put your soul into it
and you know when you've done that
because it's gripping when you write
it's meaningfully engaging this is
another thing that i've been sharing
with my audiences meaning is actually an
instinct like you think okay so we
already decided that incremental
self-improvement is the proper route
okay so how do you know when you're
incrementally self-improving properly
and the answer is it's deeply engaging
it's deeply meaningful and the reason
for that is you're actually adapted
neurologically to identify the pathway
of maximal incremental improvement this
is the trick though you have to pick a
path of discipline whether what path of
discipline you have to pick is a
different issue because there could be a
rule the rule might not be follow this
rule the rule might be you have to
follow some rules so it's a matter rule
and the meta rule is you have to
discipline yourself and the issue is
well how that's not really the relevant
question you can pick a disciplinary
path that's why i often tell my clients
especially young people they say well i
don't know what to do it's like that's
okay
nobody does go do something
do the best thing that you can think of
put the best plan you have into practice
it's not going to be perfect and it will
change along the way but it will change
partly because you become disciplined
pursuing the path and as you become
disciplined you become wiser and as you
become wiser you become able to
formulate better and better plans so you
can start vaguely and confused and
develop a plan that's not so great and
you start to implement it and then you
you accrue incremental wisdom as you
implement your flawed plan and that
enables you to fix the plan and so
that's part of that process of
incremental self-improvement as well
the point is your best strategic
position is how am i insufficient and
how can i rectify that that's what
you've got and the thing is you are
insufficient and you could rectify it
both of those are within your grasp if
you aim low enough aim low and i don't
mean don't aim and i don't mean don't
aim up but you have to accept the fact
that
you can set yourself a goal that you can
attain and there's not going to be much
glory in it to begin with
because if you're not in very good shape
the goal that you could could attain
tomorrow isn't very glorious
but it's a hell of a lot better than
nothing and it beats the hell out of
bitterness and it's way better than
blaming someone else it's way less
dangerous and you could do it and what's
cool about it as you start to fail you
fail more and more rapidly but it also
means that as you start to succeed you
succeed more and more rapidly and so you
take an incremental step and well now
you can lift 55 pounds instead of 52.5
pounds you think well what the hell's
that it's like it's one step on a very
long journey and so it's it and it
starts to compound on you so a small
step today means puts you in a position
to take a slightly bigger step the next
day and then that puts you in a position
day and you do that for two or three
years man you're starting to stride
i don't know how many people have come
and told me it's so strange they said
well i started making my bed and that
made all the difference
it's like well yeah you decided to aim
up man and the first concrete
instantiation of that was that you made
your bed you think well that's nothing
heroic it's like no but aiming up is
heroic that's something and then
lowering yourself to the point where
you're not above the mess in your room
you know you're not super ordinary to
that you lower yourself so that you
straighten up you you're grateful for
what you have right in front of you and
you take care of it you put it in order
it's like all of a sudden things start
to get better
you